Musik Einen wunderschönen guten Abend, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer Ausgabe von Das Podraskovo mit der Matize. Wahnsinn und Florentin Will. Ja, und natürlich. Chef Matize, Wahnsinn und Florentin Will. Genau. Ja, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid und natürlich herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen Gala, eingeleitet von keinem Geringeren als natürlich der guten alten Druckluft-Bande, da ist sie mal wieder. Druckluft erzeugt schöne Töne, ihr wisst es, der Flo von Druckluft hat uns dieses Intro eingesandt, aber da waren natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr Leute beteiligt und deswegen vielen, vielen Dank an dieses herrliche Intro mal wieder, es ist immer wieder ein Highlight. Manchmal freue ich mich das ganze Jahr drauf. Ich freue mich auf Weihnachten, Urlaub und auf ein neues Intro von Druckluft. Ja, und vor allem ärgere ich mich, dass wir nicht mehr Intros hatten, lange Zeit, die sich so iconic eingebrannt haben, dass es Sinn macht, die von Druckluft interpretiert zu bekommen. Das stimmt. Wir haben halt nur dieses eine. Das wird halt jetzt in verschiedenen Stilrichtungen
von Druckluft interpretiert, was voll cool ist.
Ich wünsche nur, wir hätten mehr.
Aber ich finde ja, da ist noch viel
Potenzial da, denn du kannst da so viel
reinblasen. Du kannst so viel reinblasen
in so ein Instrument, das ist wirklich gar kein Problem.
Also da geht einiges. Naja, je mehr Luft
man holt. Ich habe so ein paar
Tests jetzt gemacht. Es gibt so Navy Seal
Tests im Internet, ob man geeignet ist, Navy Seal zu werden. Jetzt nicht alle Tests kann man machen, aber den Luftanhalten Test. Okay. Den kann man sehr gut machen. Da gibt es dann so einen kleinen Zeitding, so ein grüner Balken, der so vollläuft. Und da habe ich Luft angehalten. Und die Kommentare unter diesem Video waren so, habe ich nicht geschafft, habe ich nicht geschafft, ich habe es ohne Probleme geschafft. Oh, nicht schlecht, du hast ja sogar legendärerweise mal in der Live-Show die Luft angehalten und hast da nicht 15 Sekunden geschafft. Ja, das war ganz wenig. Also das war, vielleicht ist das jetzt ein Versuch, hast du seitdem daran trainiert, dass du diesen kleinen Makel auf deiner ja sonst lupenreinen Karriere vielleicht wieder ausgleichen kannst? Ich glaube, der Unterschied ist ein bisschen im Kopf. Also in einer Live-Situation wird man eh kurzatmig, man ist rumgerannt, man ist nervös, man hat Adrenalin im Kopf. Anders als wenn man jetzt vor einem Boot geworfen wird und dann lange Luft anhalten muss. Man weiss, wenn man auftaucht, dann wird man erschossen. Also das ist natürlich eine andere Situation. Das ist etwas anderes. Kann man nicht, kann man wirklich nicht vergleichen. Die Situation war jetzt bei mir unter Laborbedingungen, ich habe auf dem Sofa gelegen, habe dieses Handy in der Hand gehabt, dieses Video gesehen und dann die Luft angehalten. Wie lange hast du geschafft? Zweieinhalb Minuten. Zweieinhalb Minuten? Wahnsinn! Also das hätte ich zu meinen Bestzeiten nicht geschafft.
Zweieinhalb Minuten,
ich war ja lange im Tauchkurs, konnte zweimal diagonal das Becken tauchen,
kein Problem.
Ja, aber da musst du ja wirklich auch noch
Sport machen dabei. Ich habe nur so da gesessen.
Das war dein Gesichtsausdruck.
Bisschen traurig,
bisschen matt.
Hoffentlich darf ich... Aber das ist dann auch so dieses Ding, dieses psychologische Ding, dass man nicht wissen darf, wie weit man schon ist. Ich habe nur mal eine Kurzdoku gesehen über den Mensch, der die längsten Plank der Welt gemacht hat. Beim Gucken weh. Plank ist glaube ich nicht das richtige Wort. Doch, ich glaube schon, wo man sich auf den Unterarmen stemmt, also nicht ganz Liegestütz, sondern so die Unterarme am Boden. Ja, wir kennen alle einen Plank. Weil es ja auch den Plank-Trend gab und da lag man einfach nur am Boden. Ach, den Planking. So, das war ich nicht. Das war einfach lang auf dem Boden liegen. Und da war so, der wollte dann irgendwie keine 24 Stunden, irgendwas absolut Absurdes und da stand dann, das hat er in der Öffentlichkeit gemacht und da stand dann ein riesiges Schild, sag mir nicht, wie weit ich schon bin, sag mir nicht die Zeit. Weil wenn du dem gesagt hättest, oh, du hast schon 18 Stunden geschafft, wäre so, oh nee, dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr. Nee, es war nämlich genau anders, bei diesem Video wurde dir ja gezeigt, wie viel du noch brauchst. Und das hat dir geholfen? Voll. Okay. Man weiss ja, krass, es war die Hälfte, mir geht es noch richtig gut und jetzt den Rest beile ich jetzt durch. Aber ich habe so wenig Selbstdisziplin. Also du bist genau anders als der Plankman, der gerade nicht wissen will, welche Uhrzeit ist, sagt mir nicht, was das Wetter draußen ist. Ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht, wie er das wissen kann. Ich will nichts wissen, ich will gar nichts. Ich will einfach in einem leeren Raum sein. Ich verstehe überhaupt, kann ich nicht mal nachvollziehen, wie er das hinkriegt dann. Na, da müssen wir ihn wohl selber fragen. Und hier ist er, Richard. Steve Cambring. Hey, guys. Hey, er wird die Rede. Hallo, Leute. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Well, I planked for a very long time. Naja, ich habe sehr lange geplankt. Du weisst, wenn du sehr tief in den Plank bist, es gibt nur den Plank, es gibt nichts anderes. Wenn man nur ein bisschen abblänkt wird, dann verliert man den Plank. Es geht nur darum. If you get distracted only by a little bit, you lose the plank, you know, it's all plank, you got a plank in and there's nothing else like it. It's the best feeling in the world to lay there for 24 hours and suffer incredible pain and insanely agonizingly painful. But as long as I don't know where I am, and as long as nobody tells you my name, what the weather is, what the numbers in the lottery are, then I'm good. I mean, I don't know. Don't tell me the time, don't tell me the coordinates where I am, don't talk to me, maybe just don't talk to me, don't tell me what you've eaten this day, was ich wissen möchte, was ich denken möchte, ist Plank, Plank, Plank, Plank, Plank, Plank, Plank. Ich war es 24 Stunden lang, Plank, Plank, Plank, Plank. Okay, ja, danke, Steve. Vielen Dank. Danke dir. Ciao. Und ich glaube, am Ende hat er es auch geschafft. Und er hält den Rekord für die... Blank, blank, blank, blank, blank. Ich glaube, er hält aktuell den Rekord. Ja, den Rekord für den nervigsten Interviewpartner und für den längsten Plank. Das ist so, beim Zugucken tut mir das schon weh, Planks. Ja, furchtbar. Das mache ich auch, ist auch in meiner Gym-Routine, ist auch Plank. Ah, nee. Bei mir war nur eine Minute, nur eine Minute, aber mit zehn Kilo auf mit drauf. Aber da willst du, starst du da auch auf die
Uhr oder willst du, oh die Vögel? Doch, ich starre auf die
Uhr. Wahnsinn. Ich starre auf die Uhr.
Ich glaube, es gibt Menschen, die
können gut mit klarer Information
und es gibt Menschen, die können gut mit Ablenkung.
Ich weiss nämlich noch im Tauchkurs, als wir nämlich auch
eine lange Strecke tauchen mussten, ist der Tauchlehrer
mit uns mitgetaucht und hat mit seinen
Fingern so Sachen immer. Hat mir berührt, dich berührt.
Hat mit seinen Fingern die Badehose ausgezogen. Weil er meinte, wenn du abgelenkt bist, kannst du weiter tauchen. Was hat er dann gemacht? Wenn du an was anderes denkst. Zeig an dieser Puppe, was er gemacht hat, wo er dich berührt hat. Wenn du an was anderes denkst und Angst hast oder so. An was zum Beispiel? Naja, woran du denkst, also was halt dir in den Kopf kommt. Und dann kannst du weiter tauchen. Das heißt, der ist immer mit uns mitgetaucht und hat immer verschiedene Sachen gemacht, auch an sich und so und dann waren wir halt abgelenkt. Und das scheint ja eine generelle Idee zu sein, dass man, wenn man abgelenkt ist, man entspannter ist und länger Luft anhalten kann oder was auch immer, aber du bist anscheinend ganz anders als alle anderen. Musst du für dich dann auch so einen Fernseher runterlassen unter Wasser, wo ein SpongeBob läuft, damit du auch mal ein bisschen weiter tauchen kannst. Für den Weltrekordversuch.
Ich will Dune sehen.
Ja, das ist
Amazon Prime. Ja, dann müsst ihr das
halt kaufen. Ja, dann kauft halt Amazon Prime.
Ja, hier hat niemand ein Account.
Guinnessbuch. Was ist das für ein Laden?
Schwimmfahr in Ebersberg, SV Ebersberg.
Wir haben kein Prime-Abo.
Wir haben besorgt Zeit. Dann tauche ich nicht.
Dann tauche ich nicht. Wir brauchen dich. wir brauchen dich um unsere Erzrivalen Ebers-Grafing-Stadt. Grafing war die Nachbarstadt, wo ich auch zur Schule gegangen bin. Was? Tief gehasst habe, ja, tief gehasst habe. Ich habe mich eher so infiltrierend darunter begeben. Aber meinte, also wenn ich glaube... Das sagt aber viel über dich aus. Ich glaube, es macht was aus dir, wenn du als Kind in der Feindesstadt zur Schule gehen musstest. Oh ja, stimmt. Guter Punkt. Es gibt zwei Arten von Menschen. Die, die in ihrer eigenen Stadt in die Schule gegangen und die, die in der Feindstadt, die sich immer verstellen mussten, die immer nicht ihre religiösen Riten zeigen konnten, die ihre religiöse Kopfbedeckung abnehmen mussten, bevor sie in die Schule gegangen sind. Die Tattoos bedecken mussten. Die Tattoos bedecken, anders sprechen. Also normal darf ich nicht sprechen, sonst können sie meine Herkunft. Genau, wie der Ebersberger Dialekt. Sonst wäre ich sofort zusammengeschrieben. Du musst dich verstellen. Deswegen, du wirst dann eher Performer, Schauspieler, denkst dich in andere Welten hinein. Bist du in Siebler. Du musst mehr den Raum lesen. Du bist in Siebler, du bist mehr in deinem Kopf. Und deswegen bist du jetzt hier Podcaster und die nicht, die in ihrer Heimatstadt
zu Hause sein können. Ja, gut.
Die Grafinger.
Ja, das stimmt. Der hat seine Wohnung und einen guten Job.
Genau. Ne, ich meine, aber
es lief wahrscheinlich daran.
Ich bin in Carmen aufgewachsen
und in Carmen zur Schule gegangen. Oh, und deswegen bist du ein ganz
platter, eindimensionaler Typ.
Ne, weil ich bin ja, komme ja aus Südcamen.
So,
und dann gab es natürlich die
Da haben wir doch einen von den Südcamenern.
Carmener!
Carmener! Carmener, Carmener, Carmener,
Carmener, Carmener, Carmener!
Was hast du für ein, das ist nicht so eine
Ariel-artige
Unterwasser.
Ich war doch nie
in Carmen. Einmal warst du in Carmen
Vielen Dank. Was hast du für ein, das ist nicht so eine arellartige Unterwasser. Ich war noch nie in Carmen. Einmal warst du in Carmen und ich habe gesagt, dann komme ich vorbei und besuche dich mal in deiner Heimat und du bleib mir fern, bleib mir fern, wicht. Und ich dachte mir, oh, okay, krass, da ist aber jemand sehr der für dich in seiner Heimatstadt. Ja, man geht mit Fremden da nicht so gut um und ich habe dir nicht zugetraut, dass du da, Kamenner, Kamenner, Kamenner, ja genau, das hast du auch gemacht, lange, bei der Autofahrt dahin, da habe ich gesagt, nee, vielleicht ist es nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt. Ist mega unsensibel und so, nach den grossen Krabbenkriegen, als wir angegriffen wurden von den Hummern damals. Das war ein Riesenproblem für uns. Die haben sich von der Nordsee komplett quer durch Deutschland geschlagen, ohne entdeckt zu werden, um dann direkt Carmen im Herzen zu erwischen. Das war unglaublich. Logistischer Akt, der so auch nie wieder wiederholt werden konnte von der Naturkriegsführung. Unglaublich. Unglaublich. Ich glaube, wenn ich einen Weltrekord schaffen würde, dann, also es gibt ein Szenario, das wünsche ich in meinem Kopf herbei, weil ich bin, ich sag mal so, ich bin ein relativ tiefer Mensch. Und damit meine ich jetzt gar nicht im Sinne von tiefgründig, sondern räumlich, weil ich trage oft einen Rucksack und auf dem Rucksack nochmal meinen Kleiderbeutel drauf. Das heißt, ich bin sehr tief. Ja, wie ein Flunder. Ich bin
nee, ein Flunder ist ja flach.
Aber tief. Aber tief.
Aber jeder Fisch ist tief.
Ja, aber habe ich ja nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, jede Flunder.
Also sag einfach ja. Ja, ja, klar.
Wenn du nachher einen besonders flachen Fisch genommen hast.
Also einen Fisch genommen hast. Fisch hat ein Cockpit ja auch vorne.
Ein Fisch hat ja einen Cockpit.
Also der Mensch ist ja eigentlich sehr... Warum du jetzt daran aufhängst? Ich meine nur, ich lag nicht falsch mit dem Flunderbeispiel. Nein, du lagst nicht falsch, aber es war einfach nicht klar kommuniziert. Nee, doch. Es ist ein super tiefes, tiefes Lebewesen. Das stimmt. Der Mensch normalerweise ist eigentlich gewohnt, dass Augen und du passt schon. Dahinter kommt nicht mehr viel. Der Mensch ist wie ein Seepferdchen. Ja, genau. Wohingegen der Fisch hat ja sein Cockpit vorne und dann noch einen ganz langen Körper. Genau. Und so bin ich auch. Und deswegen immer, wenn ich einkaufen gehe, wenn ich aus Hamburg komme mit meinem Beutel, mit meinem Kleiderbeutel, bin ich wahnsinnig tief. Und meine Vorstellung natürlich ist, dass ich irgendwo im Weinabteil bin. Genau. Und in das Regal. Und ich drehe mich um und ich räume einfach das gesamte Regal ab.
Und dann erschrecke ich und drehe mich nochmal in die andere Richtung und räume einfach nochmal komplett alle Whisky-Schnapsflaschen ab.
Und dann rutsche ich aus und räume einfach nochmal komplett alle Sirups.
Dass das Regal umfällt gegen das andere Regal und der ganze Rewe von außen betrachtet einfach so Atompilz.
Oppenheimer.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das Bild,
das ich immer von mir im Kopf habe. Ich glaube, wenn ich
einen Weltrekord schaffe, dann für
die am meisten abgeräumten,
tief abgeräumten
Strike-Homerun
Gefäße mit einer Drehung.
Daran arbeite ich einfach. Und du hast auch noch den Domino Day geschafft. Genau. Damit du über das als größe Kettenreaktion. Das ist deine Angst. Einfach hinter mir alles komplett ab. Es ist so, und jetzt sagst du was. Angst ist ein Wort, aber es ist auch ein Bedürfnis. Weil wenn du ganz lange Angst vor etwas hast, dann willst du ja irgendwann, dann soll es einfach passieren jetzt so.
Das ist wie in einem Horrorfilm, du hast immer Angst vor dem Monster, aber du willst es irgendwann, komm, wir gehen es dahin, ich will es sehen, konfrontieren und dann will es auch gut sein. Du hast ja in dir so ein bisschen auch die Hoffnung, dass wenn man dann einmal die Gefahr sieht, merkt, ah, so schlimm ist es gar nicht, einen gewissen Erlösungscharakter hat. Klar, du rennst weg, wenn es ein kurzer Schrecken ist, aber wenn du in einem vergeisterten Haus wohnst und dich immer versteckst und denkst, das ist jetzt auch jetzt irgendwann müssen wir den Geist angehen so und dann, das ist genau bei mir das Problem. Ein Pärchen, was das Problem wegschiebt. So ein Pärchen, das ist immer so ein Film vor, die progressieren halt einfach, die hören diesen Geist oben, die gucken Fernsehen und oben hört man so und den so.
Schalten wir nochmal auf RTL zwei um?
Ja, genau. Schatz, ich habe darüber nachgedacht, wir sollten uns dem Geist probieren.
Es nervt halt einfach.
Schau mal, was aus Vox läuft.
Nee, aber Schatz, ich will auch.
Nein, Hilfe, Hilfe! Jetzt macht er wieder das junge Mädchen, macht er jetzt wieder. Ja, das haben wir jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal. Wollen wir uns dem Problem mal widmen oder so? Nee, weil, Schatz, ich habe ja als wir im letzten Haus ja, aber als wir im letzten Haus waren, habe ich mich um den Geist gekümmert. Lass uns das morgen mal. Aber immerümmerere ich mich um den Geist. Das wird so ein Problem wie so Müll rausbringen. Ich habe mich letzte Mal das ... Ja, aber Schatz, du kannst das ja auch gut. Zusammen sein, zusammen sein. So, du läufst von dem Geistproblem weg. Morgen fahr ich in Urlaub. Du fährst morgen in den Urlaub. Können wir das nicht nach dem Urlaub machen? Mit den Jungs. Ja, mit Jungs, mit Paule. Mit Paule. Boah, das wird wild. Und du weißt, dass der Geist dir folgt. Du weißt, dass der Geist dir folgt. Ja, das ist kein Problem. Ich bin froh, dass du immer weg bist, weil dann habe ich das Geist gegeben. Aber stört dich das nicht. Ja, schon, schon. Aber es ist halt, ja, komm, okay, dann machen wir es halt. Weil so ist es doch. Weil ich finde es lustig, in normalen Situationen, wenn man ein Geräusch hört, man kümmern sich nicht sofort drum. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Man denkt, ah, vielleicht haben wir Ratten auf dem Dachboden. Aber alle Pärchen in Horrorfilmen ist direkt immer, wir kümmern uns sofort drum. Was ist das für ein Geräusch? Wir gehen dem sofort auf den Grund, um dann herauszufinden, ah es sind eben keine Ratten, ah wir haben einen Geist, ah shit shit shit, wir holen uns das Medium und gucken irgendwie, wie wir das Problem gemeinsam gelöst bekommen. Und dabei sterben Menschen und es wird ein Horrorfilm. Aber die normale Idee wäre ja, erstmal das so lange herauszuzögern, ignorieren, weil das geht schon von alleine weg. Ich meine, mir sind auch schon Dinge passiert, wo ich mir denke, oh, völlig ignoriert.
Ich stand letztens zum Beispiel in einem Buchladen am Bahnhof,
dann schaue ich so ein Buch rein und dann sehe ich, wie aus meiner Nase ein Bluttropfen runterfällt,
ich sehe es in der Perspektive, auf meinen Schuh.
Ich mache gar nichts. Auf den Schuh? Auf den Schuh. Ich dachte, es fällt auf das Wort Bahnsteig. Auf das Wort morgen. Ja. Ah, ich glaube, ich muss los zu meinem Zug. Auf das Wort ICE 327. Genau, auf mein Handy. Genau auf den Zoom. Ja, das finde ich gut. Das wäre auch gut. Das wäre schade. Aber ich einfach, und dann ignoriert man es einfach. Das ist in der Trailer-Man, man fährt nach Hause und fährt gut nach Hagen, Hagen umsteigen, alles gut. Das wäre mal eine gute Werbung übrigens. Ah, stimmt. Also pass auf, pass auf. Die Werbung ist, Typ geht in Buchhandlungen und guckt sich das irgendwie an und so und liest sich ein Buch durch und es fällt ein Stück, es fällt Blut aus seiner Nase, tropft auf das Wort Autofahrt und dann so, Schatz, kommst du, kommst du? Und er so, okay, legt sie irgendwie weg und steigt draußen mit seiner Frau in den Volvo ein und fährt los und Und dann einfach nur, Volvo, Sie brauchen sich keine Sorgen machen. Sie fahren Volvo. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Sie brauchen sich keine Sorgen machen. Ja, finde ich wirklich schlecht. Das sicherste Auto, wahrscheinlich, weil die Volvos gewinnen ja immer irgendwie, bei diesen Crash-Tests immer sicherste Auto der Welt. Das hässlichste Auto, ja. Nee, sicherste Auto der Welt. Achso, das sicherste, aber hässlichste Auto? Und dann einfach Volvo, das sicherste Auto der Welt. Das finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Sie brauchen sich keine Gedanken machen. Ja. War das nicht stark? Weirdeste Werbung der Welt. Das sicherste, aber hässlichste Auto? Und dann einfach Volvo. Das sicherste Auto der Welt.
Sie brauchen sich keine Gedanken machen.
War das nicht stark?
Weirdeste Werbung der Welt.
Man hat auch kein Blutzeigen in Werbung natürlich.
So Schatz, mir ist heute Morgen so ein alter verzottelter Mann aufgetaucht, der meinte, wir sollen auf gar keinen Fall mit dem Auto nach Nürnberg fahren.
Schatz, wir haben Volvo.
Das sicherste Auto der Welt. Neben nicht. Neben nicht. Ach Gott. Der Cutter hat es wieder völlig missverstanden. Das fände ich ja so eine coole Werbung. Das ist eine gute Idee. So Omen, so ein furchtbares Omen. Ja. Oder so ein, meinetwegen, das mit dem Blut ist, natürlich ein sehr spezielles Szenario, aber wenn in so ein Ouija-Brett irgendwie, Warnung, Autofahrt, Autobahn und an dem Mistach steigen sie ein.
Und trotzdem, weil sicherste Auto der Welt.
Ja, das finde ich super.
Finde ich gut.
Finde ich auch gut.
Jetzt schicke ich es wieder an meinen Werberkumpel und er sagt wieder, es wird nicht gemacht werden.
Die sind dann immer so angepisst, es muss viel klarer in der Botschaft sein. Ja, aber was ist denn die Bote, der mir beobachtet, mir beobachtet, mir beobachtet, mir beobachtet, mir beobachtet, mir beobachtetpot produzieren, dann kann uns Volvo verklagen? Ja, machst du Volvo. Vulva. Schlechtes Beispiel jetzt, aber du machst... Ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt noch mit Blut und ist natürlich jetzt noch noch viel verwirrender, ne? Nee, ich weiß nicht. Vulva. Das sicherste Auto für Sie. Was? Was, was, was, was, was? Volvo und Vulva? Nee, ach, nein, nur weil wir nicht ... Wir konnten nicht Volvo benutzen. Sorry, in der Endcard auf YouTube. Nein, sorry, sorry, sorry, weil wir durften nicht das Wort benutzen, sorry. Wir haben es verändert, damit noch klar ist, dass es Volvo ist, weil es wichtig ist für die Sicherheit. Wir hätten BWM nehmen sollen, habe ich gesagt, aber Stefan wollte unbedingt Volvo nehmen. BWM. BWL. Das ist eine gute Werbung. Ich finde, das ist eine super Werbung. Wir sollten viel mehr Werbung machen, finde ich, oder? Ah ja, Werbung liebe ich. Ich glaube, das können wir richtig gut, oder? Also das könnte ich den ganzen Tag machen, Werbung. Guckst du auch gerne Werbung? Mittlerweile ja. Mittlerweile ist man für den Werbespot so selten ausgesetzt, dass ich die schon noch nicht mehr gerne gucke. Auf Twitch und so, da gibt es dann, also gibt es halt immer die gleichen so, aber ansonsten. Leute, die ich da immer gucke, denen folge ich dann. Ja, ja, ach so, ja, nee, das stimmt. Aber so, ja gut, da hast du recht. Aber sonst habe ich selten Werbung gerade irgendwie im jetzigen Leben, ausser man guckt mal linear Fernsehen, weil man irgendwie Sportarten guckt oder
sowas und dann mal linear guckt, dann hat man ab und zu Werbung und dann gucke ich immer
ganz aufgeregt. Was ist das denn? Ich habe zuletzt Werbung in den 80er Jahren gesehen.
Ich habe zuletzt Werbung in den 80er Jahren gesehen. Stell dir mal, du bist 94 geboren.
Aber still, dann gucke ich das gerne. Werbung ist nicht schlecht. Es ist nicht schlecht. Nee, es ist nicht schlecht. Es ist nicht schlecht. Nee. Es ist nicht schlecht. Was ist dein Sommeressen? Ich bin tatsächlich gerade so ein bisschen hin und hergerissen zwischen Kirche und Erdbeere. Okay. Und ich kriege es nicht hin. Und ich bin tatsächlich, weißt du, das hat man schon oft drüber gesprochen, dass du eine Serie schaust und währenddessen eigentlich überlegst, welche Serie du lieber stattdessen schauen würdest. Und du deswegen das gar nicht genießen kannst. Und so ist bei mir Kirschen und Erdbeeren gerade so ein bisschen. Wenn ich Kirschen esse, denke ich mir, Erdbeeren wären geiler gewesen. Aber auch lustig, dass man Kirschen und Erdbeeren niemals zusammen ein Gericht packen würde. Genau. Nee, das geht gar nicht. Das sind wie so zwei gleich ausrichtete Magnete, die sich so abstossen. Du kannst sie nicht zusammen... Plus, super, minus, geil. Plus und minus, vorfacht. Zum Beispiel Kirschen und Brombeeren und Himbeeren. Waldbeeren. Genau, werden so grob als Waldbeeren zusammengeballert. Wohin gering, die Kirsche hängt ja jetzt mittlerweile nur noch mit der Banane rum. Hast du gesehen? Die Kirsche hat ja mit uns Waldbeeren nichts mehr zu tun. Die Kirsche ist gewisser Polyamor ein bisschen. Hat verschiedene, die probiert sich noch ein bisschen aus. Die Kirsche ist geil. So cool. Aber was mich halt ein bisschen nervt an der Kirsche, wir hatten sehr drüber gesprochen, dass es mittlerweile irgendwie, es gibt für mich Gegenschinder, die unangenehm sind, einfach so der Toaster, wo der Toast noch lange
drin ist, oder Messer und Gabel,
die irgendwie dann, die sind immer
in den getrennten Fächern unter sich, aber
auf dem Tisch liegen sie dann nebeneinander, mit jemandem, den sie gar nicht
kennen, sondern ewig lang
teilweise, und dann so
worüber spricht man so,
fängt man überhaupt ein Gespräch an, weil man wird ja eh gleich
genommen zum Essen und dann ist man in unterschiedlichen
Händen und dann wird man ja auch wieder separat gelegt. Dann kommen wir mal so näher und dann immer, hi. Und dann so, genau, weil du denkst, wenn die jetzt ein Gespräch anfangen, während wir noch nebeneinander liegen, dann muss ich während des Essens auch immer wieder, ah hi, so, wenn du schon mal so einen gewissen Grund, ah, deswegen ganz unangenehm. Messer und Gabel nebeneinander, das finde ich super unangenehm. Aber das ist jetzt bei mir auch auf Obst übergegangen. Und was ich richtig unangenehm finde, ist die Kirsche, weil das sind ja immer so zwei Kirschen zusammen, immer so zwei Brüder, so zwei zusammen und da denke ich mir auch immer so, verstehen die sich, sie sind irgendwann getrennt und dann was ist, wenn sie dann aber wieder zusammenkommen, sag mal, ah geil, du, erkennen die sich? Aber dann werden sie kurz darauf auch einfach zerfressen. Boah, aber das fände ich so nervig. Weißt du, Erdbeere so alleine, kein Problem, Apfel super. Ey, Kirschen sind so perfekt. Aber Kirschen, so diese zwei, vor allem immer so dieser Körperkontakt, ne? Die hängen ja von einem Punkt ab und kommen, dann werden sie so ein bisschen zusammengedrückt. Die hängen ja nicht frei, sondern die hängen immer so einander so ein bisschen. Wie umarmend. Warum schützt sie das? Ich finde, ich stelle mir das wie in so einer U-Bahn vor, wenn man so zusammengedrückt ist und man will da gar nicht hin. Ich stelle mir das anders vor. Ich stelle mir, dass sie halten so Händchen. Ach so, immer so. Das sagt alles über dich. Wenn man so ein bisschen Handabwischen will, kann ich so lange Händchen nennen. Was sehen Sie hier? So Assoziationstests, so zwei Kirschen, die aneinander gedrückt sind. Und du sagst, das ist wie so U-Bahn. Und ich sehe aber, die halten Händchen. Ja, aber sehen Sie hier? So Assoziationstests und dann so zwei Kirschen, die aneinander gedrückt sind. Und du sagst, das ist wie so U-Bahn und ich sehe aber halt ein Händchen. Aber was sehen Sie hier? Und dann so eine Schachtel Himbeeren. Was siehst du da? Naja, halt einfach komplett zusammengedrückt wie beim Konzert, wo einer irgendwie raus will, aber gar nicht rauskommt. Ah, ich sehe eine wunderschöne Party, wo alle sich liebhaben, sich angucken und manche küssen sich. Ja, ich bin der Negative. Ich bin ein Minus uns. Du bist das Liebe. Du bist Plus. Wir sind ja auch wie so zwei Kirschen, ne? Also wir hängen ja am gleichen Baum. Wir werden so aneinander gedrückt. Wir werden aneinander gedrückt. Aber manchmal brauchen wir halt auch unsere Zeit alleine. Holy shit, also Erdbeere verliert jedes fucking gegen Kirschen. Erdbeeren sind so scheiße. Aber ich weiß nicht warum. Bei Kirschen, immer wenn du so eine Kiste Kirschen hast, immer eine faul. Aber nur eine. Was macht die falsch? Also die muss sich da auch denken, die, warum bin ich, warum bin du, ich verstehe mir so, was habe ich falsch gemacht? Und alle so, oh Gott, also wenn du fragst, können wir dir natürlich schon ein bisschen Feedback geben. Und es ist immer eine Poker-Ton, die so einfach alles Negative. Das ist wie in diesem Koffer, wenn du einen Koffer kaufst oder du kaufst dir irgendwie Taschen oder sowas, sind da ja diese Bags drin. Genau, dieses Trockenhalten. Dieses Trockenhalten und so, wo draufsteht, nicht fucking mal nicht essen. Wie kommst du überhaupt auf die Idee, das zu essen? Ich verstehe nicht, warum es auf mich stehen muss. Warum denkst du immer an Essen, wenn du das siehst? Vielleicht weil das Wort Essen, Fett draufsteht.
Warum meinst du, alles in den Mund nehmen zu müssen? Das steht auf diesem Ding an ja drauf.
Und das ist glaube ich das, was die faule Kirsche in einem Kirscheimer ist.
Achso, ich dachte, die hat das gegessen.
Die hat das gegessen.
Den ganzen Kram.
Die ganzen Bakterien und sowas gehen halt dahin, weil da die grosse Bakterien... Genau. Ich habe doch gar nicht so viel, aber ich bin doch schon so krank. Also das Tomorrowland für Bakterien auf dieser Kirche. Und da gehen alle hin. Und dann haben die anderen Kirchen dann sozusagen beste Zeit. Ich weiß, aber ich finde es ein gutes System.
Also beim Arzt, oh ja, Kirsche
sind kerngesund, wunderbar, nächster,
sie sind kerngesund, wunderbar, in Form.
Nee, nee.
Okay, ich sehe schon in ihrem
Atem, sie haben Krebs, Aids,
Cholera, Schwindsucht,
Gelbsucht, sie haben jede Krankheit.
Oh nein.
Während wir miteinander reden, haben sie auch noch Skorbut bekommen gerade. Sie kriegen stündlich mehr Krankheiten. Kann man das heilen? Nein, das kann man überhaupt nicht heilen. Sie sind komplett verloren. Fuck it, sie sind komplett verloren. Das ist eine Kirche, die ist alles kaputt, wirklich. Die ist dann noch so, aber das mag ich wiederum an Kirschen. Wenn sie faul sind, sind sie so offensichtlich faul. Ja, sind sie so fucking faul. Wogegen bei Himbeeren gibt es so ein paar, die sehen perfekt aus, da beisst du rein und denkst, ist da drin. Aussen wunderschön, innen drin rotten. Genau, ich will Obst, dass wenn es faul ist, all in faul ist. Wirklich, gib mir Schwarz, gib mir grüne Schlieren, gib mir so diese Stinklinien, gib mir Blüten, gib mir so offensichtlich, faule Pilz, Knospen, wir reden von faul und dann esse ich dich halt nicht. Aber alle anderen schon. Es ist ja gerade Pifferlingsaison. Ich liebe Pifferlinge. Wirklich, Pifferlinge sind so toll. Und gerade habe ich irgendwie so eine romantische Vorstellung, wie ich, so in der Eifel wachsen nämlich auch ganz viele Pifferlinge, ist gar nicht so weit weg von hier, da ist einfach unberührte, riesige Natur. Bis du garst. Dann laufe ich da rum mit meinem, habe ich so ein Körbchen, ich habe genau eine Vorstellung, wie dieser Korb aussieht, so ein länglicher Korb. So ein Rotkäppchenkorb, ja. Ja, genau, aber das ist so länglich, so wo man danach so Pilze drin kaufen kann, auch im Rewe.
Ganz toll sieht der aus aus so hellem Holz und dann habe ich den rum und ich laufe da herum und die Rehe hinter mir, auch so im Hoppserlauf, laufen und ich sammle Pifferlinge. Ja, und dann echt würdest du einfach den ersten Pilz nehmen, essen und sterben. Ja, ja. Einfach sofort. Und dann gibt es tatsächlich so ein paar Pifferling-Hotspots, wo ich gehört habe von Leuten, die in Eifel sind, die bewahrt man und schützt man und verrächt die niemandem. Oh, Geheimwissen. Das ist Geheimwissen. Du willst nicht, dass Leute da auch Pifferling ernten. Ja, ja. Und die wachsen ja mega schnell nach. Du pflückst die und dann kannst du in zwei Wochen wieder hingehen, da sind wieder Pifferlinge da. Das ist mega geil. Und dann irgendwann denkt sich der Pifferling auch so, komm schon, jetzt lassen wir es, oder?
Lass mich wachsen.
Come on.
Ja, dann wachsen wir nicht mehr.
Einfach nachwachsen.
Wenn du so eine Tür hast und dann wird die geklaut.
Dann packst du eine neue Tür rein und dann ist die einfach direkt wieder geklaut.
Und du denkst dir, wer braucht so viele Türen?
Ja, du wie bei Fahrrädern.
Der Fahrrad wird immer geklaut und dann hol ich mir ein Swapfeet und dann wird es wieder klaut.
Ich bin Stocksauer gerade übrigens.
Oh, okay.
Ich bin Stocksauer übrigens.
Spannend, spannend.
Stocksauer.
Okay, auf wen?
Ich bin aufgeladen und ich bin Stocksauer, weil ich habe euch ja erzählt.
Du bist jetzt hier. Fahrer wird immer geklaut, dann hole ich mir ein Swapfeet und dann bleibt es in Amerika. Ich bin Stocksauer gerade übrigens. Oh, okay. Ich bin Stocksauer übrigens. Spannend, spannend. Stocksauer. Okay, auf wen? Ich bin aufgeladen und ich bin Stocksauer, weil ich habe euch ja erzählt, mein Fahrer... Übrigens, Stocksauer, kein gutes Wort, weil man weiß nicht, wie sauer. Wie sauer sind, also Stocksauer. Stock ist schon maximal. Stock, Stock, Stock. Ich bin stockbesoffen, ich bin stockblau. Ich bin Speerangelweit sauer und zwar, weil ich habe euch ja erzählt, ich habe ein Fahrrad besorgt, für mich natürlich introvertiert, nervig, e-bar-kleinzeigen, hingehen, furchtbar, aber dann hatte ich es. Habe ich mir ein Schloss bestellt, habe ich mir Lichter bestellt, wunderbar, Joe Blow, Luftpumpe aufgepumpt, wunderbar, fertig. So, jetzt fahre ich damit drei Wochen lang und es ist geklaut. Weg, weg. Und so, ich weiß, der Täter ist da draußen. So, und deswegen sage ich jetzt, wenn du meinen Fahrt geklaut hast, ich fordere dich heraus, in Kampf, Leben und Tod, bring deine Switch mit, ich habe eine Switch, wir spielen Mario Kart und wer gewinnt, kriegt das Fahrrad.
Best of Seven?
Best of Seven, von mir aus gerne, ohne Items.
Und ohne Rainbow Boulevard.
Aber wir gehen dann nicht ins Detail, warum ohne Rainbow Road.
Ja, und du darfst nicht Peach nehmen, aber ansonsten alles. Okay. It's on. Okay, it's on. Weil ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Mir wurden schon so viele Fahrräder geklaut und jetzt sagst du natürlich, oh, warum hast du es nicht abgesperrt? Du hast doch gerade gesagt, du hast ein Fahrerschloss bestellt. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass... Nee, du hast mehr von deiner Low-Blow-Luftblumpe erzählt. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, Joe Blow. Low Blow. Nee, ich hab Low Blow. Ich hab Low Blow, die ist so fucking low, ey. Alle Witze sind so fucking lame. Die Luft, die da rauskommt, die ist so niedrig irgendwie, die ist so... Yo, hi, ich bin Low Blow. Na, was geht, Alter, altes Haus, na? Oh Mann, was hast du an deiner Hand? Oh, ist ein kleiner Scherz. Was für ein Low-Blow-Scherz. Ja, ein kleiner Scherz. Oh, fasse dich meine Hand an. Oh, vielleicht kriegst du einen Strumpfschlag. Au, warum mache ich das dann auch noch? Low-Blow, ich bin Joe Low-Blow. Du nimmst immer die niedrigsten Früchte. Joe Low-Blow, Joe Low-Blow, Norbleu-Espanien. Jetzt dachte ich natürlich, weil ich fahre ja immer zu Rocket Beans in Hamburg mit dem Fahrrad und dachte, ich könnte es da abstellen, einfach da gibt es so einen kleinen Vorgarten, das es beschützt, stellt sich heraus, nein, anscheinend ist die Kriminalität überall und ich kann aktuell noch nicht ausschliessen, dass es einer meiner Kollegen war. Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Und ja, es gibt da so ein paar Leute, die ich im Auge habe und ich werde jetzt investigieren, weil ich lasse das nicht mehr mit mir machen. Aber haben wir jetzt so ein Agatha Christie-artiges, es kommen nur fünf Leute in Betracht, Reverend Grün. Es kommen 120 Leute in Betracht, das ist eine mehrstaffelige Angelegenheit. Ein Whodunit, wo auch was egal ist, was allen ab Moment eins egal ist, weil das Fahrrad auch nicht gut war. Reihen Sie zu, reihen Sie zu, die Idee ist ganz einfach. Wir haben am Anfang der Staffel 120 Verdächtige und mit jeder Folge fliegt einer raus. Aber lernen wir die alle kennen in Folge 1? Ja, wir lernen so die ersten 20 kennen. Und dann mit jeder Folge fliegt ein Verdächtiger raus. Und weißt du, was das Gute ist? Die Schweine können mir das nicht absetzen. Die Schweine können mir das nicht absetzen. Weil doch, es wurden schon so oft Dinge abgesetzt. Nein, nein, weil ... Ich bin die Schweine übrigens, von denen Sie pütschen.
Nein, ich bin die Schweine. Pass mal auf, oink oink, du kleines Schweinchen, jetzt pass mal auf. Wie reden Sie mit dem Produzent? Jetzt pass mal auf, kleines oink Schweinchen, ja? Kleines Schweinchen, jetzt pass mal auf. Nee, übrigens Schweinchen. Weil ich fütter dich nämlich jeden Tag mit einem Verdächtigen, der ausgeschlossen wird und erst ganz am Ende der Serie wissen wir, wer es war. Niemand interessiert sich, wer es war. Raus!
Ja, okay.
Raus!
Ja, es wird nicht gemacht.
Nein, aber Sie können nicht raus, Sie wollen noch wissen, wer es war.
Nein! Serie wissen wir, wer es war. Niemand interessiert sich, wer es war. Raus! Ja, okay. Raus! Ja, es wird nicht gemacht. Nein, aber Sie können nicht raus, Sie wollen noch wissen, wer es war. Nein, ich will nicht wissen, wer es war. Okay, ich sag's Ihnen, Folge 1, Carina war's nicht. Ja, okay, cool. Vielleicht war's Tombo. Big Tombo. Fuck, woher wissen Sie das? Ja, keine Ahnung. Ja, es war Tombo. Ja, okay, tut mir leid, das ist nämlich nicht, wer es war. Das nehme ich nicht, wer es war. Scheisse, so offensichtlich, oder was? Ja, klar, natürlich der, der am Anfang noch mega nett ist und dann am Ende kommt es auch raus, dass er böse ist. Gehe ich zu Vox. Ja, die nehmen eh allen Scheiss. Viel Spaß. Oink. Raus. Ich glaube, es wäre eine gute Serie. Aber jetzt stehe ich natürlich am Rücken zur Wand.
Nee, aber ich habe mir ein Leihfahrrad, ein Swapfeeds Leihfahrrad.
Und das wird dir nicht geklaut, weil niemand hat ein Interesse, das zu klauen, weil man kann es nicht wiederverkaufen.
Man kann es sich leihen.
Man kann es sich einfach leihen.
Es ist so klasse.
Wirklich, bei mir vor der Haustür werden minütlich Räder geklaut.
Es ist so lustig. Man kann dabei zugucken, wie sie geklaut werden. Man kann wirklich dabei zugucken. Ich kann auf das Fenster gucken und sehe, wie Leute die klauen. Ich bin schon ein paar Mal hingegangen und gesagt, Leute, hör auf zu klauen. Hör auf zu klauen und die so, ja okay, dann sind die gegangen. Ich habe mich schon ein paar Mal Fahrraddiebe konfrontiert. Du bist so ein ganz Low-Blow-Batman einfach so. Du hast so einen Punkt Kriminalität, wo du sagst, okay, Gotham braucht mich.
Bitte halt auch zu klauen, Leute.
Bitte auch zu klauen.
Okay.
Einmal bin ich rausgegangen und ich werde immer cooler bei jedem neuen Versuch, weil man
wird immer am Anfang aber noch Angst, stechen die mich ab, wenn ich die konfrontiere beim
Klauen, nachts.
Weil mein Schlafzimmer geht genau da hin raus, ich höre, wenn Leute da rumwerkeln, dann
gehe ich, beim ersten Mal hatte ich richtig Angst, dachte mir, oh, ich konfrontiere die
jetzt, ich gehe runter und habe noch mega Panik gehabt und so und dachte mir vielleicht
Das war es. Ich wollte da rumwerkeln, dann gehe ich, beim ersten Mal hatte ich richtig Angst, dachte mir, oh, ich konfrontiere die jetzt, ich gehe runter und habe noch mega Panik gehabt und so und dachte mir, vielleicht reiben die mir ein Messer in meine Rippen. Und ich werde aber immer leichtsinniger und cooler mit jedem Mal, wo ich mich konfrontiere. Inzwischen bin ich bei, kann man da nicht irgendwie helfen oder soll ich dir halt die Blödsinn holen? Egon, was machst du da wieder? Oh, ich wollte das Fahrrad klauen. Ach, lass das doch, Mensch. Ja, okay. Das gehört doch jemandem.
Ja, alles klar.
Okay, okay.
Ja, gut, ich gehe jetzt.
Jetzt mache ich Folgendes, jetzt heite ich meine Augen auf auf Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, weil es gibt einen Account auf Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, wer mal in Hamburg nach Fahrrad sucht, der offensichtlich, offensichtlich geklaute Fahrräder verkauft.
Super, super.
Und das ist ein Deal, den nehme ich an. Das ist ein Deal, den nehme ich an. Ich kaufe das jetzt zum gleichen Preis, weil es ist ein unfassbar schäbiges Fahrrad. Ich weiß nicht, wer das klauen sollte. Welcher Dieb hat so niedrige Ansprüche? Was mehr über den Dieb aussagt, ehrlich gesagt über mich. Deswegen sehe ich mich auch hier, ehrlich gesagt, als nicht der Gelackmeierte in der Situation. Weil ich finde, das sagt mehr über den Dieb aus. Und deswegen werde ich jetzt versuchen, es mir zurückzukaufen. Und ansonsten bin ich aktuell wieder fahrradlos. Ich muss cool. Ich muss zurück auf Snakeboard greifen. Deswegen snake ich. Jo, fahrradlos. Ja, danke. Deswegen snake ich jetzt, wenn überhaupt, dann wieder durch Hamburg. Snakeboard. Snakeboard. Das ist das, wo du so wackelst. Ah ja, gut. Wo du einen fantastischen Arsch von bekommst. Das ist schwer zu fahren. Wunderschönen Hintern kriegt man davon. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist mir auch direkt aufgefallen. Ja, danke dir. Als du vor mir die Treppe hochgegangen bist, dachte ich mir, trainiert er oder Snakeboard oder was ist es? Ja, ich habe jetzt wieder... Wunderschön. Das stimmt, vor allem nur zwei Stunden Snakeboard und das reicht für den... Wunderschön. Also perfekt. Fast lächerlich, also... Oh, und ich habe jetzt nicht nur, sage ich mal, körperlich bin ich nahe an der Perfektion dran. Ich habe dir erzählt von meinem Spangenproblem, Retainer-Problem, Draht im Mund. Du bist dann montags morgens entgegen meiner Empfehlung noch zum Kieferorthopäden gegangen. Genau, du hast gesagt, montags morgens keine Kieferorthopäden, weil die das Wasser nicht durchspülen. Also mein Problem war, ich hatte mein Draht lose, der Draht war los im Mundraum, Retainer, der die vorderen vier Zähne zusammenhält, festgeklebt an allen vier Zähnen, an einem hat es sich abgelöst. Also hatte ich immer im Mund so einen Draht, an dem man rumspielt, furchtbar nervig.
Also bin ich zum Kieferorthopäden gegangen, habe da ewig ausgefüllt, stellt sich raus,
die machen das nicht. Also bin ich zum nächsten Kieferorthopäden gegangen,
habe aber im Vorhinein angerufen, Klingeling, hallo, machen Sie das auch?
Und ich so, ja, ja, okay, mal Maura, so.
Die ist so desinteressiert.
Ja, die war so, ja, kann man das machen. Ja, kann man schon machen. Müssen sie halt dann selber zahlen, ne? Wirklich? Ja, ja. Was geht bei dir falsch? Müssen sie halt dann selber zahlen und dann war ich da, kein Problem, und dann ich liebe es ja, dann in diesen Wartezimmern diese Magazine zu lesen, weil die haben ja auch nicht coole Magazine, sondern sie haben einfach so nur diese Zahngesundheitsmagazine, wo irgendjemand eine Redaktion in Deutschland jeden
Monat neues Heft
Zahngesundheit rausbringen muss,
mit wirklich, aber das sind ja trotzdem so
Journalistische, die dann wirklich sagen,
Leitprodukte, Presslufthammer
für die Zähne, Fragezeichen, und du
liest es und dann hast du, ja, trinkst nicht zu oft.
Und es sind halt
vier Seiten Artikel und ich liebe das, diese unglaublichen Nischendinger. Es ist fantastisch. Und dann war ich da, kein Problem, wurde mir wieder angeklebt. Und dann war ja immer die Frage, weil ich dachte, mein Problem ist, dass ich zu einem Kieferorthopäden gehe und ich eigentlich zu einem Zahnarzt gehen sollte. Kieferorthopäden, ich habe sie ja damals als arrogant, überheblich dargestellt, die sich mit sowas nicht fachstellt. Handwerker gesagt, das sind eher Handwerker als die gelehrten filigranen Chirurgen. Genau, Zahnärzte, so und dann war die Frage, habe ich das richtig gemacht oder nicht? Zahnarzt gegen Kieferorthopäde und ich gehe zum Kieferorthopäden und es wurde mir gemacht, aber dann lag ich da, komplett lediert irgendwie und dann kam die Assistentin von dem… Warum lediert? Weil ich einfach, R Rücklage bin ich durch. Vergiss es, Rücklage bin ich komplett durch. Und ich habe mir echt überlegt, weil ich war lange in kieferorthopädischer Behandlung mit der Spange und ich habe wirklich die Fähigkeit entwickelt, vollkommen unbeeindruckt zu sein von jeder zahnärztlichen Behandlung. Ich bin einmal eingeschlafen in einem Zahnarztstuhl, wirklich dreht sich jede Zahnarztangst um, ins Gegenteil, ich bin völlig locker,
ich nicht da schlafen, so Lappen.
Zu so einer überheblichen Gelangweiltheit.
Ja, wirklich.
Das ist dann immer so, ach.
So Lappen, ich bin wie so eine Übungspuppe,
wo die Zahnärzte da so rumdrücken, so.
Ich bin einfach völlig...
Herr Will, ist ja völlig okay, dass Sie keine Angst haben,
aber die ganze Zeit zu sagen, wie langweilig es hier ist.
Boring.
Hilft er jetzt auch.
Das tut ja gar nicht weh.
Es tut mir nicht weh.
Nee, ist doch auch gut.
Ja, ist doch schön, dass es nicht weht. Es tut überhaupt nicht weh. Ja, ist doch auch gut. Ja, ist doch schön, dass es nicht weht.
Es tut überhaupt nicht weh.
Ja, aber Sie entwickeln so eine Arroganz.
Gehen Sie mal näher hier.
Gehen Sie mal näher ins Zahnfleisch.
Ah, ah, ah, so, jetzt blutet es mal richtig schön.
So, da geht doch was.
Der Hammer steckt in dem Gerachen drin.
Und dann habe ich jetzt ein bisschen Angst gehabt, weil ich lange nicht mit dem Zahnarzt war, habe ich die Fähigkeit noch.
So wie Superman, der vielleicht mal eine Woche nicht fliegt und dann sich denkt.
Eingerostet. Lieber machen, machen lieber einen Testflug, bevor ich dir vom Hochhaus springe, lieber kurz mal im Garten so, ähm, Leute, ich komm gleich, ich muss mal kurz und dann sind sie ins Badezimmer und so. Ah, das geht noch. Okay, komm, los geht's. Weil ich glaube, du hast nie wirklich das hundertprozentige Vertrauen, dass du wirklich fliegen kannst. Und so hatte ich auch nie das Vertrauen, dass ich beim Kieferorthopäden wieder schlapp sein kann. Und ich habe mich hingelegt und es war wie damals komplett entspannt locker. Und dann kommt die Assistentin rein und meinte, ja, ja, Herr Doktor, jetzt haben wir einen Wartezimmer, der hat Kiefer-Schmerzen. Und es war so völlige Ratlosigkeit. Und dann meinte er so, ja, das kommt oft zu Missverständnissen wegen Kieferorthopäde. Und ist sie wieder gegangen. Also anscheinend war das gar kein Kieferorthopäde, sondern Zahnarzt, der aber häufiger das Problem hat, dass er mit einem Kieferorthopäden verwechselt wird. Weil der Zahnarzt kann ja nicht
kann ja nichts gegen Kieferschmerzen
machen. Doch, ich glaube,
du warst bei einem Kieferorthopäden
und da war jemand mit Kieferschmerzen,
der hat aber nichts beim Kieferorthopäden
zu suchen. Der Orthopäde
ist der Knochenmann,
der rumhandwerkende
Hammermann.
Und der muss zum Zahnarzt gehen, um eine Spritze zu rein zu bekommen gegen die Kieferschmerzen. Weiß ich nicht. Weil es ging dann noch weiter, da meinte er so, ja, ja, kleben wir an, kein Problem. Jetzt schauen wir uns mal ihre Zahnzwischenräume an. Ah, da ist ja ein bisschen Karies. Oh, da braucht es eine Füllung. Stellt sich heraus, es war einfach ein Zahnarzt. Ah, okay. Ich glaube, es war ein Zahnarzt, der sich verkleidet hat, um sich reinzulocken.
Und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich es jetzt richtig gemacht oder falsch?
Weil ich dachte, ich gehe zum Kiefer-Tabell, aber anscheinend habe ich es fälschlicherweise richtig gemacht.
Wenn er ein Problem gelöst hat, ist es doch gut.
Und er meinte dann auch so diese klassische Frage, wo man sich wieder sechs Jahre alt fühlt.
Wann waren Sie das letzte Mal beim Zahnarzt?
Also, 1895. Wann wurde die Golden Gate Bridge eingeweiht? Also das war so kurz nach der Errichtung des Golden Atoms. 16, 18, es war Mittwoch. Das war Frau Ramses der Zwei. Aber da unterscheiden wir uns schon sehr. Weil ich hab ja mein Stempelheft. Nee, ihr habt nix, ihr habt gar nix. Hast du kein Stempelheft? Ich hab gar nix, bin völlig blank. Jedes Jahr? Und dann so, ja, dann müssen wir aber schon mal gucken, oder einfach schön geröntgt, bam, zack. Und jetzt brauche ich auch irgendwie eine Füllung, irgendwas, ob ich gar nicht gechecke, was genau gefüllt wird, womit, mir egal. Sollen die machen, was sie wollen. Aber ich fand es interessant. Aber Moment, hast du noch nie mit deinem Ohrending, wo du deine Ohrenkamera auch mal den Mund untersucht? Ja, hab ich auch. Und da hast du nicht gecheckt, dass du Füllung brauchst? Nee, weil ich auch nicht weiss, was eine Füllung ist. Aber er meinte auch so, ja, das sieht alles gut aus, aber erst das Röntnerapparat hat das dann freigelegt. Und es ist dann auch so die Frage so, ja, wie oft benutzt du denn Zahnseide? Und du hast sofort wieder diesen Schulbubeninstinkt zu lügen. Ja, hab ich auch immer. Warum? Es ist so dumm. Und du so, naja, also, naja, zwölf Mal. Aber das Problem ist halt, genau, es fehlen einem halt der Maßstab. Genau, die Parameter, wo du genau ansitzen kannst mit der Lüge. Man weiss nicht genau, also soll ich sagen viermal im Jahr? Ja. Es ist lächerlich. Also so zwanzigmal im Jahrzehnt. Am Tag, im Jahrzehnt. Im Jahrhundert, im Millenium, im Millenium. In so pro Dutzend Jahre. Also pro Epoche 250. Meinen Sie jetzt im Schaltjahr oder im normalen Jahr? Nee, einfach durchschnittlich im normalen Jahr. Ach so, nie. Genau, das ist der eigentliche Trick, immer Rückfragen stellen. Genau.
Meinen Sie es morgens oder abends?
Meinen Sie es pro Woche oder? Achso, machen Sie es pro Woche.
Achso, nee, null.
Um herauszufinden, was der Maßstab ist. Genau.
Meinen Sie es pro Jahr?
Ja.
Achso, ja, genau.
Keimer.
Und dann verkackt man es dann doch.
Und ja, ganz merkwürdig.
Also es scheint, denen scheint häufiger das Problem zu haben, dass die Zahnzt sind, aber mit einem Kieferorthopäden verwechselt werden, was ungewöhnlich ist, weil man findet sie, wenn man Kieferorthopäden googelt, aber ganz merkwürdig, weil der wirkt ja auch enttäuscht. Der meinte so, ah, Kieferschmerzen, der meinte so, ja, dem kann ich nicht helfen, wir sind ein Zahnarzt. Ich würde ihm so gerne helfen, aber ich habe ein Studium zu schlecht.
Herr Doktor, da ist jetzt einer im Wartezimmer, der will 200 Gramm Mortadella.
Das gibt immer wieder Missverständnisse, aber ich kann Ihnen leider nicht helfen.
Hörst du, ich kann Ihnen nicht helfen.
Herr Doktor, gut, dass Sie da sind. Ich habe mich leider aus meiner Wohnung ausgesperrt. Können Sie mir helfen? Ich würde Ihnen so gerne helfen. Aber ich kann nicht. Ich bin ein Arzt. Ich bin ein einfacher Arzt. Ich habe Schlüsseldienst gegoogelt. Ich kann Menschen zum Leben erwecken wieder. Ich kann Menschen von Krebs beheilen. Ich kann, ja, ich habe sogar mal einen Retainer wieder angebracht. Ihr Name kaufte auf, als man Schlüsseldienst gegoogelt hat. Aber ich kann Ihnen nicht die Tür aufbrechen. Okay? Gehen Sie da raus. Finden Sie einen Schlüsseldienst, der dafür gemacht ist. Okay. Und öffnen Sie Ihre Türen. Dann schreiben Sie halt bitte nicht Schlüsseldienst auf Ihre Website. Ja, das wollte ich noch ändern. Das ist für die SEO halt so gut, ne? Das steht alles drauf. So, wenn du bei deinem YouTube-Video alles in die Tags haust, das war ja früher so der Geheimtipp. Früher habe ich ja einen nicht geringen Teil meines Lebens damit verbracht, nachzudenken, wie man schlechte YouTube-Videos trotzdem gut... Du hättest darüber nachdenken können, wie man besseren Content macht. Richtig. Dann hast du dich überlegt, nee, wie überliste ich die SEO? Nee, ich habe mir überlegt, nee, ich mache mir zehn Fake-Accounts und sobald das Video online geht, schaue ich schnell mit allen Fake-Accounts das an und like, damit der Algorithmus denkt, boah, das Ding geht durch die Decke, damit der das dann weiterverbreitet, damit es tatsächlich durch die Decke gehen kann. Und da gab es ja immer so dieses Geheimding Tags, so das war die Anfangszeit, so Big YouTube und dann so, du musst immer in die Text, musst immer irgendwie Justin Bieber wet, irgendwie Big Dick reinschreiben, alles mögliche, einfach damit es gut im Algo kommt. Genau. Hat wahrscheinlich nie gestimmt, aber trotzdem. Aber es wäre sehr gross in dem Magazin Algo. Wenn du da bei YouTube im Wartezimmer sitzt, dann hast du das Magazin Algo. Da warst du ganz prominent drin, weil du gut in der Algo funktioniert hast. Das finde ich sehr gut. Mir ist euch aufgefallen, mir geht es ein bisschen auf die Nerven, wie sehr, sagen wir mal, so Services wie YouTube oder Spotify oder auch eBay meine Beziehungen zu Freunden zu kennen. Denn, Beispiel, man teilt etwas. Ich teile Musik von Spotify mit einem Kumpel oder einer Freundin. So, dann schickt man denen das und dann steht oben drüber, hör doch in dieses Album mal rein. Man denkt, was glaubt ihr die Beziehung zu der Person, der ich jetzt gerade Musik schicke? Ja. Hör doch hier mal rein. So schreibe ich da nicht mit Leuten. Und alle, alle, alle. Der macht einen vorgefertigten Text, eine Nachricht. Okay. So, und ich finde das so lustig, weil YouTube macht auch. Schau doch dieses YouTube wieder mal an. Genau, ja. Und man denkt immer, was glaubt ihr, was die Beziehung zu Leuten ist, denen man sowas schickt, weil diese ganzen Websites, die meinen immer so zu wissen und bei, bei eBay, sehr übergriffig, eBay Kleinanzeigen, habe ich neulich nach vorne was geschickt, was ich kaufen wollte, und ich wollte ihr nur sagen, was ich kaufen will, wofür ich mich entschieden habe letztlich. Aber der Teilenbutton hat daraus gemacht, was hältst du hier von? Was hältst du hier von? Und dann der Link. Und dann kriegt sie drauf und hat dann gesagt, was sie davon hält. Ich war nicht an ihrer Meinung interessiert. Ich wollte nicht ihre Meinung wissen dazu. Die Meinung musst du dann wieder an Ebay zurückführen, so als würden die ein Gespräch führen und du bist nur der Vermittler. Vielen Dank, Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, für diese Frage. Ich war nicht an der Antwort interessiert, ich habe es bereits gekauft. Ich will nicht wissen, was sie davon hält. Ich wollte es ihr schicken, damit sie gefragt hat, wofür hat sie dich entschieden, ich habe es geschickt. Ich bin nicht an ihrer Drecksmeinung interessiert.
Ja, ja, du müsstest eigentlich so einen Regler haben, so.
Welche Beziehung haben Sie zu der Person, mit der Sie teilen?
Völliges Desinteresse, reiner Informationsabtausch, sehr freundlich.
Warum teilen Sie gerade diesen Link?
Genau.
Wollen Sie dieses Lied a. empfehlen?
Wollen Sie davor warnen?
Wurden Sie nach diesem Lied gefragt?
Wollen Sie damit angeben, was Sie für einen coolen Musikgeschmack haben?
Hör doch. Dann würden wir Ihnen eher das Lied empfehlen.
Hör doch hier mal rein, Kumpel.
Hör doch hier mal rein, wollen wir mal was essen gehen?
Das ist so eine Art Wingman.
Aber wollen wir mal Zeit zu zweit verbringen?
Ja, wollen wir diesen Song vielleicht mal zu zweit anhören, an einem See?
Das Kendrick Lamar.
Ja.
Okay, aber ich kenne den Song. Okay. Und die zweite Frage? Hat Spottifall das rausgemacht oder wolltest du, Vince? Ja, nee. Aber das stimmt. Man kann das ja verfälschen und sagen wir mal, abfälschen. Und dann so tun. Genau, wenn du dir nicht sicher bist bei jemandem. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann kannst du sagen so, hey, wollen wir zusammen miteinander schlafen?
Und dann antwortet sie so, hä, was ist das für eine Nachricht?
Und so, hä, das war die automatische Generierung von Spotify.
Da ist es ein bisschen zu weit gegangen.
Aber der Gedanke war ja gut.
Also, wenn man zum Beispiel daraus macht,
wollen wir diesen Song mal zu zweit
hören? Und dann
sagt sie, nee, du weißt ja,
ich bin jetzt noch mit Carlo zusammen.
Ach so, ja, ja, na Quatt, Spotify hat Spotify draus gemacht. Spotify macht gerade so weirde Nachrichten draus. Und Spotify hat zwei Rechtschreibfehler eingebaut. Schick Nudes. Du hast mir Justin Bieber Sorry geschickt. Ja. Aber warum steht da Send Nudes? Ich will dir keine Nudes schicken. Ach so, irgendwie, das ist keine Ahnung, du musst von Spotify automatisch generiert sein oder so, aber also, wenn du willst. Hier schicke ich dir auch einen Song. Schick mir nie wieder eine Nachricht. Okay. Bei dir steht jetzt hier, schick mir nie wieder eine Nachricht. Genau. Und dann das Schweinchen-Emoji. Mhm. Aber dann der Song, hast du den Song gehört? Der Song ist cool, aber die Nachricht, warum hast du die Nachricht geschickt? Nee, nee, das war Spotify automatisch. Ach so, okay, alles klar, okay. Und dann schreibt man die ganze Zeit in so einem Code. Ja, finde ich auch gut, immer die Links. Aber ich finde es so übergriffig. Deswegen meine Nachricht an euch da draußen. Liebe Tech-Unternehmen, ich finde, ja. Schraubt euch ein bisschen zurück, nehmt euch ein bisschen zurück. Niemand ist interessiert daran, irgendwie an diesen vorgefertigten Nachrichten. Wollen wir hier eine Nacht zu zweit verbringen, bei Airbnb zum Beispiel. Genau. Macht. Auch übergriffig. Wenn du einfach nur zeigen willst, wo du bist. Für Florentin und mich geht's bald nach New York. Kann man ja mal offen sagen. Wir freuen uns sehr darauf, dieses Jahr machen wir New York-Urlaub und gerade ist die Airbnb-Zeit auserkoren. Wir gucken ein bisschen nach Airbnb-Wohnungen. Ich gucke nach Airbnb-Wohnungen. Das macht so Spaß, zwei zu shoppen nach Wohnungen und sich wirklich so ein gemeinsames Leben aus. Und da jede Wohnung, die ich dir schicke, ist immer mit tollen Nachrichten versehen. Was hältst du hier von? Wollen wir hier mal eine unvergessliche Nacht gemeinsam verbringen? Dabei ist meine Botschaft eigentlich Sag einfach Ja. Sag einfach Ja zu diesem Link. Ich schicke dir den nur aus Höflichkeit Doppelprojekt. Genau, ich hab schon gebucht. Ja, ich habe schon gebucht. Ich schicke dir nur aus Höflichkeit den Link, damit du mir nicht die Vorwürfe machen kannst. Ich finde, es ist ein kritisches Thema, weil es ist natürlich nervig, diese automatisch generierten Nachrichten, aber ich finde, der nackte Link muss in gewisser Weise auch eine gewisse soziale Ächtung erfahren. Als Menschen einigen wir uns auf gewisse Konventionen, man niest Menschen nicht einfach direkt ins Gesicht. Da muss man nicht, oh das wüsste ich ja nicht. Ne, das macht man nicht. Ich finde, wir brauchen natürlich die Online-Etikette, da habe ich schon oft darüber gesprochen. Und ich finde, ein Teil davon sollte sein, man schickt nicht einfach nackte Links. Vor allem nicht an Menschen, die man nicht kennt. Also ich kriege das ganz oft so bei Instagram, einfach klatscht mir jemand einen Link hin oder auch auf Reddit postet jemand einfach einen nackten Link. Das geht nicht, das sollte man nicht machen. Anmoderieren. Kurz anmoderieren, kurz erklären, damit ich grob weiß, worum es geht. So wie Stefan Raab damals so Clips angekündigt hat. Wo er meistens auch schon, und achten Sie mal an der Stelle drauf, was der Clown dann macht. Genau. Weil Stefan Raab war das lustigerweise immer schon sehr gut, also eigentlich hat er schon verraten immer. Aber man hatte Bock, es dann auch zu sehen. Ja genau, aber ich wusste genau, worauf ich achten muss. Und so, wenn ihr mir einen langen Link schickt, zehn Minuten lang irgendwie ein Interview, was Lustiges drin passiert, cool. Sagt mir, achtet aber auf die Gorillas im Hintergrund. Genau, ja, ihr müsst mehr so wie Buzzfeed denken, dass ihr sagt so, boah, bei Minute drei, achtzehn, ich glaube, das wird dir besonders gut gefallen. Genau. Sowas in der Richtung. Ich finde, der nackte Link ist durch. Wir haben dieses Internet jetzt schon lang genug benutzt. Ich glaube, es sollen sich gewisse Verhaltensweisen rauskristallisieren. Super. Nackte Links, ich bin noch nicht so weit, dass ich es generell blockiere oder so, aber ich bin auf dem Weg dahin, gewisse Massnahmen zu ergreifen, die auf euch herabprasseln werden wie der Zorn Gottes. Nackte Links sind nicht so schön auch, ne? Gerade bei Instagram-DMs, die werden dann so einfach, sind dann diese Hyperlinks, sehen gefährlich aus, sehen aus wie so, man wird reingeloddelt in so einen Spam-Scam. Ein Link ist eh schon so ein komisches Ding so, was man schickt. Ich meine, das ist so, wie wenn wir irgendwann, keine Ahnung, irgendwie so alte Briefverkehre oder so, wo man dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Napoleon und irgendeinen Kaiser oder Freud und Jung oder so, wo man dann anhand der Briefverläufe dann nochmal so ein bisschen die Beziehung rekonstruieren kann. Napoleon schickt dann so LOL und dann so einen TikTok-Link. Genau, einfach nur so einen Link und die Forscher fragen sich, was genau wollte er damit aussagen? Naja, LOL, es könnte eine Abkürzung sein für ... Libertatis Omnis Leonis, ja, Freiheit allen Löwen. Genau, richtig. Aber warum jetzt genau ein Video von so einem Wackelpudding, von einer nackten Frau in Form eines Wackelpudding in Form einer nackten Frau, das so hin und her wackelt? Genau, jede solche Frage, war es einfach ein humorvoller Austausch? Ja, genau. Oder war es eine Kriegserklärung? Weiss es nicht genau. Keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet. Das ist schwierig. Also denkt bitte an die Historiker und Archäologen, Paläontologen, die das alles eines Tages ausgraben müssen, euren Quatsch da. Genau, denkt generell an die, bei allen Dingen, die ihr kommuniziert miteinander, immer schön daran denken, wenn andere das lesen würden, hätten die auch so viel Spaß wie ihr. Genau. Dann entsteht auch, glaube ich, weniger Streits. Es kann passieren, dass es irgendeine Höhle ist, die irgendwann mal gefunden wird, wo die Leute so Höhlenmalerei haben. Ich bin tatsächlich gerade so ein bisschen im Werner Herzog-Fieber und schaue mir einige seiner Filme nicht ganz an. Und es gibt einen Film über so eine uralte Höhle, weil es gab ja mal so eine uralte Höhle, die gefunden wurde mit ganz alten Wandmalereien. Genau, gab es die eine Höhle. Mega geil, Leute, 15 Euro Eintritt, let's fucking go! Stellt sich raus, wenn da hunderte Menschen drin atmen, dann wachsen da irgendwelche Pilze über die Malereien und fressen das weg und es ist einfach ruiniert. Menschen haben es einfach zerstört. Da hat man noch eine Höhle gefunden und er gesagt hat, okay. Hier machen wir alles anders. Hier machen wir alles neu und nur Werner Herzog durfte mit seiner Crew rein und da sind halt teilweise Höhlenmalereien drin, die wurden angefangen, da hat jemand so ein halbes Gnu gemalt und dann kam irgendwann jemand anderes, hat dieselbe Höhle gefunden und hat das Gnu fertig gemalt. Und man hat dann diese Radiocarbon-Analyse gemacht und hat festgestellt, dass zwischen dem ersten Künstler und dem zweiten 5000 Jahre liegen. 5000! Also das ist so, wie wenn wir heute zu den Pyramiden... Mach den Test noch mal. Ah, jetzt kommt zehn raus. Ah ja, okay. Ah, okay, gut. Also, ach so, im Ausversehen entstehen dahinter genau. Genau weil ich verrechnet das irgendwie. Stell dir vor, jemand geht heutzutage zu den Pyramiden und sagt, wir bauen das jetzt zu Ende einfach. Aber können wir ohne Scheiß? Also, erst mal muss ich sagen, sorry, aber ihr habt euch einfach gar nicht weiterentwickelt in den 5000 Jahren. Ich meine, das Gnu sah damals scheiße aus und der zweite Künstler hat sich auch nicht gut verbessert, also das war nix. Ich meine, wie kann in 5000 Jahren so wenig passieren? Ich meine, schau dir heute mal irgendwie Pharao an und dann heute ein Gif. Da ist eine Menge passiert und da ist gar nichts passiert.
Nee, aber oh Scheiss, lass kurz, einmal muss ich kurz eine Abzeigung nehmen, weil irgendwie andauernd liest man oder sieht man in Videos, krass, können wir mal klären, wie haben die Ägypter Pyramiden gebaut, wie konnten diese antiken Kulturen das hinkriegen, Pyramiden zu bauen. Liegt's an mir oder ist das nicht die einfachste fucking Form der ganzen Welt? Und natürlich bauen antike Menschen mit geringen Möglichkeiten die einfachste fucking Form der Welt. Vier Kanten und in der Mitte läuft's gerade hoch zu. Wahrscheinlich kippt es nicht um. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Genau. Nehmen wir mal eine einfachere Form. Es ist eigentlich die simpelste Form. Wie haben die das gemacht? I couldn't care less. Wahrscheinlich haben sie lange, die hatten viel Zeit. Ich habe das im Alter von sechs Jahren aus Lego gebaut. Das ist das simpelste, was man bauen kann. Ich verstehe Taj Mahal oder so. Okay. Der Koloss von Rodos. Ich verstehe es. Sphinx, von mir aus. Die hängenden Gärten. Kann man auch erstmal hinkriegen. Ich verstehe alles. Geil. So. Pyramide ist das Einzige, was ich verstehe. Egal wie hoch die ist. Ich verstehe es. Ist sogar treppenförmig gebaut. Wahrscheinlich kann man am Rand einfach irgendwann hochgehen. Ja, ich meine, und dann, oh, lass uns mal auf einen komplett anderen Kontinenten fliegen, gerade nach Südamerika. Oh, stellt sich raus, die haben das gleiche gebaut. Die haben auch die einfachste Form gewählt. Die sind auch auf die brillante Idee gekommen, rechteckige Dinge auf rechteckige Dinge zu legen. Oh, es muss Aliens zu tun, es muss was mit Aliens zu tun haben. Anders kann man sich nicht erklären, wie alle Kulturen sich auf diese Form entschieden haben. Hey, Moment mal, hey, stopp mal, die haben einfach die normalen Steine genommen und so aufeinander gelegt, dass sie am Stabletzen sind. Komm, dann gehen wir jetzt einfach was trinken und haben einen schönen Abend. So spreche ich immer, egal ob es mir gut geht oder nicht. Was darf es für Sie sein? Ich hätte gern einen Kölsch und bitte noch die Pommes dazu.
Okay, alles klar.
Sir, ich habe mich gefragt, kann man hier drinnen rauchen oder muss ich dafür rausgehen?
Nein, Sie müssen dafür rausgehen, bitte.
Zu den Aliens.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Danke für die Information.
Warum hängen wir mit dem Typen nochmal?
Ist das Herrenklo besetzt oder warum?
Kann ich es nicht öffnen?
Es ist aktuell besetzt, ja. Da ist jemand drin.
Vielen Dank. Wir wissen nicht, wer da drin ist.
Wie lange ist das Herrenklo
schon besetzt? Vielleicht sind
Aliens da drin. Dieser NTV-Sprecher ist der unangenehmste Typ der Welt, glaube ich. Todbringende Aliens. Aber ich denke mir, bei Pyramiden, da muss man ja schon relativ den grossen Wurf wagen, weil du musst ja die Fläche am Anfang legen fest fest, wie hoch das Ding auch wird. Aber selbst dann, nein, nein, das ist das Schöne, ist so fucking lame, natürlich. Aber da sind ja auch Räume drin und so, also du kannst ja nicht einfach sagen, grösser. Machst du da wieder rein, machst du nachher nicht rein. Ich glaube einfach, die haben diese riesen Fläche gemacht und dann eine Schicht und dann, ja, jetzt sind wir tot. Das war ein bisschen zu gross, oder? Jetzt sind wir leider schon tot. Ich finde Pyramiden, also, was ist das? Ja, ich meine, ja, ich verstehe es. Es ist einfach, es sind vier Seiten, das ganze... Ja, aber warum sind sie denn nach Ägypten gekommen und haben diese Tour gebucht? Ich will es mir mal angucken, weil alle reden davon und finden es immer so cool und so und ich dachte die ganze Zeit... Ja, es ist halt nur ein Dreieck, ja. Ja, aber es ist uralt und riesengross. Ja, aber natürlich ist es uralt, also wenn das heute gebaut würde, würde jeder sagen, also was bauen wir denn da für Bauwerke gerade und da gehen unsere Steuergelder hin. Ja, aber es ist achttausend Jahre alt, da waren sie noch nicht mal am Leben. Ja, aber natürlich bauen die dann das, ist ja nichts dran, es ist ja kein Nullig verziert. Ja, oh mein Gott, und wir bauen einen Kölner Dom und trotzdem ist er ja nicht uninteressant. Der ist mega spannend. Jeder baut halt das, was er kann. Ja, aber trotzdem muss man ja nicht Eintritt für verlangen. Es sind vier Seiten. Vier Seiten, die gleich gross sind. Ja, ist schon ein bisschen. Ein von fünf Sterne, Pyramiden von Gizeh. Wirklich, lame. Lame Form. Ist nicht so meins. Und in diesem Moment, wenn die Folge rauskommt, ist die abgehoben, ist einfach, ist es die Pyramide, Aliens, es waren die ganze Zeit. Es waren doch Aliens, das wäre richtig gut. Aber sind die hier früher auch draufgeklettert, oder war das wie so eine Art Bank, oder dass sie dann irgendwie so pausenmässig dann so, äh, lass uns in der Pyide treffen, ey, hast du gehört, Clara, äh, Clara, aber keiner weiß das ägyptische Namen, ey, Clara, ja, Clara und Fred, äh, an der Pyramide, die sassen, Ramses, Ramses hier, die waren ganz oben und dann so die Kinder klettern einmal ganz rauf oder so, oder war das verboten, war dann da wirklich so Schlangensperrkrieger, die eine Schlange an den Speer gebunden haben, um dann damit die Leute runter zu quengeln oder was auch immer.
Ja, genau das war ja der Weg, mit dem die das gemacht haben. Sorry, ja genau, das wollte ich nur einwerfen kurz, weil das ist wirklich so. Ja, Pyramiden sind enttäuschend, okay, ja. Ne, genau, also weil manche Dinge werden einfach so hochgejazzt, so hochstilisiert und ich finde so, ah, alle krassen antiken Kulturen und Zivilisationen haben Pyramiden gebaut. Ja, obviously. So was man sonst bauen, so einen grossen Ball, der wahrscheinlich nicht. In Wolkenkratzer wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Irgendwie den Fernsehturm? Ja, Turm. Turm wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Wollen wir nicht mal in eine Höhle gehen? Pass auf. Und dann malen wir. Lass uns gemeinsam eine unvergessliche Nacht
in dieser Höhle verbringen.
Stefan, was hast du mir da wieder für einen Link geschickt?
Nee, das war Airbnb.
Ja, schick mir einfach einen Link zur Höhle.
Genau. Wollen wir in diese
Fickhöhle eintauchen? Hä, Stefan?
Wollen wir Sex
in dieser Fickhöhle haben? Hä, irgendwie deine Nacht?
Da ist nicht immer ein Link drin.
Ah, ah. Warum genau wollen wir in einehöhle haben? Hä, irgendwie deine Nachricht? Da ist nicht immer ein Link drin. Ah, ah, ähm. Warum genau wollen wir in der Höhle? Also, wir wollen die wegatmen. Nein, nein, pass auf, aber lass mich doch nochmal ausreden. Ich verstehe nicht, ich will zu hören, was ich vorab, in der Höhle zu machen. Auf zu atmen, Stefan! Können wir in diese Höhle gehen und wir malen an den Rand banale Formen, banale Botschaften, Mahirngnu, Madansel, Santile. Also du meinst in eine moderne Höhle, um Leute zu foppen? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, in eine alte Höhle, um Leute zu foppen. Okay, okay. Okay? Ja. Und wir gehen rein und sagen, wir haben da was gefunden, als wir im Wald spielten, als wir uns nicht mit Stöckern im Wald spielten, als wir mit Stöckern im Wald spielten, fanden wir eine Höhle. Ich meine, es ist eine berechtigte Frage, finde ich, weil wir hatten irgendwie Joe A, der malte ein halbes Gnu, Joe B, 5000 Jahre zweiter Teil des Gnus, warum kann jetzt nicht Joe C, ich, hingehen und dem Gnu noch irgendwie so einen coolen Laser-Raketenaufsatz malen oder so.
Warum, was macht mich schlechter als
Joe B, weil es muss ja auch irgendwie weitergehen, oder nicht? Klar, die Kunst muss immer weitergehen. Und ich meine, das waren ja erwachsene Leute und ich kann besseres Gnu malen als die. Erstens nein, erstens nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Nein, nein, nein.
Die waren so fucking...
Hä?
Ja, aber für die Abstraktion, für die Abstraktion, für deren Stil.
Hatten die Stil, hatten die verschiedene Stile? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein wie bei den Dinosaurierforschern, deren Job ist es darzusetzen und einfach Vermutungen anzustellen. Weil das wirst du schlicht nicht mehr lösen, das Problem. Niemand weiss, warum der Typ... Das kann gut sein. Jeffrey, komm mal kurz. Was denn, was denn, was denn, was denn? Was ist denn? Warte mal. Komm mal kurz hierher. Ich habe ja die ganze Zeit jetzt hier an dieser Malung... Ja, du bist unser begnadetster Künstler. Ja, genau, ich habe die ganze Zeit an dieser Wandmalerei. Geil, geil, geil, das ist fertig geworden. Okay, guck dir das mal, guck mir das Bild an. Hey ihr beiden, kommen wir zum Essen? Was ist los? Ja, gleich, gleich. Was ist los? Warum lacht ihr? Joe B. hat ein Bild gemalt. OOOOOOOOH! NEIN! Was? So geht das die ganze Zeit. Fuckin. Bis alle fünf Stammesmitglieder es gesehen haben. Es kann auch ein Witz sein. Und dann starben alle. Alle starben, weil... Wahrscheinlich wegen todbringenden Aliens. Ihre laute Lache schallt durch den ganzen Wald und hat Säbelzahntiger und todbringende Aliens angelockt. Der achtbeinige Büffel könnte auch ein todbringendes Alien sein. Aber niemand weiss es. Aber ich finde gut, dass du immer der Forscher bist, der sagt, Leute, es war ein Witz. Aber warum hat die Figur zwei Köpfe? Ist das eine Art von Gottheit? Es war ein Witz! Okay. Okay? Ja, kann es schon sein. Es war ein Witz. Nee, es war ein Witz, dass es ein Witz ist. Hä? Ja, Leute, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Koffe. Haut rein, haut rein, haut rein, haut rein, wir geben ab, tschüss, tschüss, Gott, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche. Ja, macht rein, haut rein, haut rein, haut rein, neben dem ab. Ciao, drrrr, tschüss.
Gott, mir überstürzt.
Nach so einem Orkwitz schlecht.
Was ist los?
Überstürzt.
Ja, haut rein, ciao.
Was ist mein Worst-Persed?